-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I'm here with our very own
Tariq Trotter from The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And we are going to play
"Virtual Reality Pictionary."
Here we go!
-♪ "Virtual Reality
Pictionary" ♪
-First, we're going to
need more players.
Joining my team is
an award-winning
writer and comedian,
who has a new one-man show,
"The Old Man and the Pool."
Give it up for Mike Birbiglia!
-♪ "Virtual Reality
Pictionary" ♪
-Birbig.
-Good game. Good game.
-Good luck.
-Good luck, yes.
-Joining Tariq's team
is an Emmy-nominated actress
and star of the new movie
"Meet Cute,"
premiering tomorrow
exclusively on Peacock.
Please welcome Kaley Cuoco!
-♪ "Virtual Reality
Pictionary" ♪
-The best. Got this.
-Hi.
I'm nervous.
-You got this.
-I'm nervous.
-No, don't be, don't be.
-The game works
exactly like Pictionary,
except the person
who is drawing will be wearing
one of these
virtual-reality headsets
and drawing in 3-D space using
a program called Tilt Brush.
Okay? We'll be able to see their
point of view
on the big screen behind us.
I will go first.
You guys can all
take your seats and enjoy --
Mike, this is me and you, bud.
What number shall I choose?
-5!
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-Wants 5.
-Came in strong.
She came in strong.
-Wow, is that someone --
Yeah, it's not rigged.
We've never met each other.
Came in hot.
No one else yelled any other --
They're like, "Well..."
and she was like, "5!"
Alright.
-Numerology fans.
-Fantastic. Yeah, I love it.
Okay, okay, okay.
-Just give it up.
Just give it up, man.
-No, hold on.
When you see this,
you're going to freak out,
because I don't even know what
I'm looking at right now.
Alright, ready?
Okay. Ready, bud?
-Yeah.
-Here we go. Um, um...
-Terrible.
-[ Laughing ] "Terrible."
-Alright. Circle. Pumpkin.
Uh...
[ Laughs ] Wait.
-Alright, sorry.
Alright, sorry, sorry.
-Okay. Nothing.
That was nothing.
This is a skull of some kind.
This is a pipe. Smoking a pipe.
A world, some kind of world --
Beard.
A beard and goggles
and a helmet.
It's a helmet that you wear for
bicycling or ski jumping or...
Ooh!
Football! Football helmet!
It's...
[ Laughter ]
-Why is it big?
-It's a helmet. It's a helmet.
Is it a sport
where you wear a helmet?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cymbal crash, sad tuba plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was awesome.
-Well done.
-I don't know.
-Quarterback.
-Oh! Quarterback.
-Yeah, sorry. I should have
used the space more.
Okay, sorry about that.
Alright, Tariq, you're up next.
So you can show Kaley
how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And pick a number first.
-What number are we going for?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Okay, easy. Easy-peasy.
Alright. Cool.
-Okay.
-This is the closest I've ever
come to being in a rave.
-It's something.
-Alright.
Whenever you're ready, Tariq.
-Yeah, okay, cool.
-Oh, there's the button.
Oh, nice.
Circle. Face.
-Wait. What is this?
Subject -- what is this?
-Oh, a face, a nose, a mouth.
-Tariq, what subject is this?
-It's a thing. Like, can I...
[ Laughter ]
-Hair?
Squiggly hair.
-Quarterback.
-A quarterback.
Ponytail?
-Yes.
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
-Ponytail?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good job!
-We did it!
-That was great! Oh, my God.
-Ponytail? Was it ponytail?
-Nice job.
-Ponytail. Alright.
-See? Synergy.
-Oh, man.
-Thank you.
-Yeah. Alright.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-So, alright.
I was gonna say, Mike --
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Oh.
Oh. I heard 2. I heard 2.
I heard 2.
-Yeah.
You got the crowd on your side.
Birbigs, we got this, bud.
Come on.
-Okay, it's a thing.
-Okay, a thing.
-I'm allowed to say "a thing."
-That breaks it
down to a lot -- very --
It's a thing.
Okay, here we go.
It's a heart. Love.
It's a cherry.
It's a jack-o'-lantern!
-Yes, it is.
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Connect it to the...
Wow! That was good.
It's connected --
-I have broken the game!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I win!
I just went from
virtual reality into reality!
-Yes, I know. It changes a man.
-Here you go.
Kaley, that's for you.
-I'm going to take these off,
because you almost
literally died.
I feel like this is,
like, very dangerous.
-Yes, it's very dangerous
and slippery.
-It's a dangerous game.
-Thank you, thank you. Okay.
-Okay. Oh, wait.
Which number, guys?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-1?
3, 3.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's a thing.
-Okay.
-It's a thing.
-You can put them on.
-You're gonna hand me those?
Okay. Alright, here we go.
-Yep.
-A puzzle. Is it -- A map.
-What do you mean
you're not good at this?
You're fantastic at this.
-Oh, it moves.
-You can move around too, Kaley.
-Oh. Oh.
-Yeah, make it
three-dimensional.
This is good. Tariq, guess.
-A map.
-Tariq, how are you
not getting this?
-A bat.
[ Laughter ]
-This is good.
Guess. Tariq, guess.
-A haunted house.
-What -- Yes.
This is good, Tariq.
Tariq, go with it.
-Free-associate.
You got to free-associate.
-Come on, bud.
-The forest.
-You're getting there.
You're warm, you're warm.
-Jungle. A tree.
-You are so close.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
[ Cymbal crash, sad tuba plays ]
-Oh.
-Do you want to take a guess?
-No.
-No, just tell us.
-I have no idea, but --
-A corn maze.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
That's fantastic.
-In the maze.
-Frightening. Oh, frightened.
Yeah, that was so good.
-Thank you.
-Kaley, it is time
for the final round,
and it's going to be a showdown.
Mike, you're going to draw this.
-I'm drawing? Okay.
-Yeah. Now, here's the deal.
If Tariq or Kaley gets it before
me, they win the game.
-Oh, gosh.
-Oh, we can all guess?
-Yes. You guys
can still win this.
-Okay.
-What number? What number?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
I hear 4.
I hear 4. Okay.
-I'm not looking. Not looking.
-Oh, wow! My God!
My God.
-We've got this, buddy.
-My God!
-We got this.
-The theme is thing.
-I'm seeing --
-Is this right?
-Seeing an image --
Am I having a --
-No, no. No, we lost it.
--Mike, I think
you're having a stroke.
Everything else is...
-Everyone can see it?
-Hey, guys, this is perfect.
For the final round...
-Old school.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Thank you.
-For the final round --
-Okay.
-For the final round,
we're going old school, okay?
-Okay, okay.
-This is the marker.
This is the way
to do it right here.
This is how you do Pictionary.
Here we go.
-Okay, okay.
-Alright. Okay.
Can you say if it's a thing
or an object or --
-It's a thing.
-It's a thing again.
-That doesn't really help.
-First of all, we'd like to
see it on this side, too.
-Yeah, sorry.
-Thank you.
-It's a thing.
And, Jimmy, if you don't get
this, then it's on you.
[ Laughter ]
If you don't get this,
then it's on you.
-Then it's on me.
-Great.
-Yeah.
-Okay, cool.
The Riddler.
-Ready?
-Yes.
-And go!
Egg!
-Candy cane.
-Dinosaur.
-Dinosaur. Oh, yeah.
-Horseshoe.
-Pitcher.
-Iced tea.
-Waterfall.
-Trumpet. Saxophone.
-Turkey!
-Oh, yeah, turkey leg!
-Peacock!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Well done. Well done.
-Peacock. All in the family.
All in the family. Yeah.
My thanks to Kaley Cuoco,
Mike Birbiglia.
More with Kaley after the break.
Stick around, everybody!
Old school!